und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen ganz offiziell
gesehen haben wir noch eine
bundesverteidigungsministerin
tatsächlich aber kocht in Berlin die
Gerüchteküche wer denn jetzt auf
Christine Lambrecht folgen wird die
selbst noch gar nicht gesagt hat dass
sie zurücktreten will die entsprechende
Meldungen aber auch mit keinem Wort
dementieren lässt das Amt ist zu wichtig
für eine lange Hängepartie die Weltlage
ist zu brisant es stehen wichtige
Entscheidungen an alle Augen sind jetzt
auf den Kanzler gerichtet Frank Buchwald
so richtig wohl gefühlt hat sie sich
wohl nie in ihrem Amt dass diese
Lambrecht bei einem Truppen Besuch im
Februar nun so heißt es in Berlin tritt
die Verteidigungsministerin den
geordneten Rückzug an höchste Zeit
findet ihr Opposition sie ist von Anfang
an mit dieser Aufgabe überfordert
gewesen sie hatte offensichtlich auch
wenig innere Einstellung zur Bundeswehr
es wäre gut wenn das was jetzt seit
mehreren Stunden als Gerüchten durch die
Medien geht endgültig mit einer
Entscheidung des Bundeskanzlers
abgeschlossen wird der Kanzler jedoch
hält sich bedeckt Scholz heute in Lubmin
an der Ostsee erweitern Flüssigkeit
Terminal einem Kanzleramt glühen zur
gleichen Zeit wahrscheinlich die Drähte
das Verteidigungsministerium gilt als
Schleudersitz in lubminen sind Fragen
zum Thema Lambrecht ausdrücklich nicht
erwünscht manche versuchen es trotzdem
vorstellen
Scholz lächelt und schweigt
Ministerin Lambrecht gilt schon lange
als angeschlagen 5000 Helme für die
Ukraine Flüge mit so einem Hubschrauber
zuletzt ein misslungenes Video aus der
Silvesternacht
damit verbunden waren für mich ganz
viele
besondere Eindrücke die ich gewinnen
konnte viele viele
also ich glaube auch dass sie sehr
unglücklich agiert ist in ihrem Amt ich
muss persönlich sagen dass ich die
Anschaffung von bewaffneten Drohnen und
atomwaffenfähigen Kampfflugzeugen einige
skandalöser finde als das Silvester
Video auch wenn das ziemlich peinlich
war kam Flugzeuge Drohnen diese Welt
blieb wohl auch Christine Lambrecht
immer fremd zurück der Rücktritt für die
Ministerin fast wie ein Befreiungsschlag
und nicht nur in Berliner Bendlerblock
fragen sich nun viele wer ihr wohl
nachfolgen könnte im
Verteidigungsministerium
ja bevor wir über diese Frage sprechen
also nach vorne gucken ist es ja schon
eine merkwürdige Situation guten Abend
schockunterla wir zwei haben ja gestern
schon drüber gesprochen all das wird von
der Regierung offensichtlich
kommunikativ gar nicht mehr gesteuert
wie lange kann sich denn der
Bundeskanzler so eine Hängepartie
leisten
also wenn Olaf Scholz auf eine Sache
wert legt dann darauf das Personalfragen
diskret und in seinem Tempo gehandhabt
werden und gelöst werden und das hat bei
der Kanzlerkandidatur bei seiner eigenen
geklappt und es hat auch bei der Bildung
seines Kabinetts geklappt da war immer
sichtlich stolz drauf und beides also
Diskretion und sein Tempo das ist jetzt
ordentlich schief gegangen in diesem
Fall offensichtlich weil die Rücktritts
Überlegungen an die Öffentlichkeit
geraten sind bevor er die Nachfolge
regeln konnte er muss jetzt also mit
Hochdruck daran arbeiten eine Lösung zu
finden und eines geht dabei nicht er
kann nicht auf eine Lösung zurückgreifen
die schon mal erprobt war nämlich den
Posten einfach mal eine Zeit lang
unbesetzt lassen das gab es wie gesagt
schon mal als Franziska gif Franziska
Giffey von vom Amt der
Familienministerin zurückgetreten ist
damals musste Christine Lamprecht den
Job einfach mal ein paar Monate mit
erledigen das geht beim
Bundesverteidigungsministerium schon den
normalen Zeiten nicht und das Recht
nicht in Zeiten von Ukraine Krieg wo
auch international Führung und
Stabilität im Bundesministerium für
Verteidigung erwartet wird das geht
nicht schon unter der guckt man nach
vorne was geht denn in welcher
Zwickmühle ist der Bundeskanzler bei
dieser Personalfrage denn jetzt ja er
muss jetzt sehr schnell jemanden finden
der am besten zwei Kriterien erfüllt
nämlich zum einen muss es eine Person
sein die möglichst ansehen mitbringt und
auch Fachkenntnisse und
Durchsetzungsvermögen auf diesem
schwierigen posten um Scholz
versprochene Zeiten wenn in der
Sicherheitspolitik umzuwenden umzusetzen
und auch längst überfällige Reformen in
der Bundeswehr an der ja schon viele
Vorgänger und Vorgängerinnen gescheitert
sind und zum anderen sollte im Idealfall
auch das Geschlechterverhältnis im
Kabinett nicht verrutschen denn er hat
ja einmal ein Verhältnis von 50 50
Männern und Frauen versprochen da ist
jetzt eben die Frage will er dabei
bleiben dann müsste er eine Frau nach
besetzen und ansonsten müsste er ein
größeres Stühle rücken in Gang bringen
es wäre jetzt der typisch für Olaf
Scholz wenn er versuchen würde eine
Lösung im kleinsten Kreis und möglichst
noch an diesem Wochenende zu finden
damit es nicht wieder den Indiskretionen
gibt und damit er auch wieder Herdes
Verfahrens wird okay das Wochenende ist
ja auch morgen noch Thema wird uns
erhalten bleiben herzlichen Dank für
heute Abend
an der Abbruchkante in Lutzerath dem
Weiler im rheinischen Braunkohlegebiet
war die Polizei gestern noch sehr
zuversichtlich die komplette Räumung sei
keine Frage von Wochen mehr sondern von
Tagen heute ist die Lage dort
zwischenzeitlich eskaliert und es kamen
deutlich mehr Teilnehmer zu einer
Demonstration gegen den Kohleabbau als
erwartet die Polizei spricht von 15.000
die Veranstalter von 35.000
es sind dann leider doch diese Bilder
die sich einprägen die Polizei wie sie
gegen Aktivisten vorgeht die in die
Ruinen von lützerath und an die
Abbruchkante drängen lebensgefährlich
für alle aufgrund des aufgeweichten
Bodens am Rand
mehrere tausend haben teilweise versucht
in Tagebau einzudringen das ist auch
teilweise gelungen andere haben versucht
hier Polizeiketten zu durchbrechen in
Richtung lützerat dabei musste
unmittelbarer Zwang angemeldet werden
sprich es kam zum Einsatz von
Schlagstock und Pfefferspray das waren
sehr unschöne Leute
völlig friedlich dagegen ist die
Stimmung in Demonstrationszug am Morgen
als ich viele sehr viele Menschen rund
um blitzerer treffen um ihre Meinung zu
sagen
[Musik]
ich bin symbolisch hier weil ich für
mich ist das wichtigste zeigen dass das
nicht meine Meinung ist was passieren
wird und ich habe auch gedacht ich muss
jetzt gehen weil wenn ich irgendwann
Kinder habe den kann ich nicht erzählen
ich war nicht hier will mir sieht was
hier an Massen bewegt werden muss und an
den Energie erstmal reingesteckt werden
muss um ein bisschen Energie aus dem
Boden zu holen ja äh das System ist
krank und eigentlich tot aus der
Wissenschaft kommt Unterstützung für die
Demonstranten das Deutsche Institut für
Wirtschaft liegt eine Studie vor darin
heißt es Zitat Lutzerath muss und darf
nicht zerstört und abgebaggert werden
wenn die Klimaziele eingehalten werden
sollen und die Energiewende wie geplant
umgesetzt wird
RWE und Politik ziehen andere Studien zu
Rate die den abbau- und lützerath bei
vorgezogenem Ausstieg aus der Braunkohle
für notwendig halten
prominentestes Gesicht auf der Demo
heute die schwedische klimaaktivistin
Greta Thunberg sie zeigt sich schockiert
vom Anblick des Tagebaus und fordert die
Menge auf weiter für lützera zu kämpfen
jahrzehntelang wurden die Menschen davor
gewarnt mit business as usual
weiterzumachen und die Wissenschaft sagt
klar die Kohle muss im Boden bleiben
stay in the ground und dann gibt es doch
noch irgendwoher den Aufruf zum Tagebau
zu stürmen dem tausende der Teilnehmer
folgen und damit fast dem Ansinnen der
Demonstranten schaden
was Benjamin Netanjahu das
Stehaufmännchen der israelischen Politik
der Premierminister mit den meisten
Regierungsjahren in Israels Geschichte
davor hat das ist ein hemmungsloser
Angriff auf das Justizsystem das kommt
nicht von mir das sagt die oberste
Richterin des Landes in Israel haben sie
Angst um ihre Demokratie das heißt der
eine Teil hat Angst der andere hat
netanjahoo bei der Wahl gerade wieder
eine neue Koalitionsregierung ermöglicht
keine andere zuvor war je so radikal
rechtslastig wie diese die Opposition
fühlt sich überrollt Staatsstreich
Regime Wechsel sogar Bürgerkrieg das
sind die Szenarien vor denen sie jetzt
warnt heute abend gehen in Tel Aviv 10
Tausende auf die Straße von dort jetzt
Michael
trotz heftiger Regenfälle sind an die
hunderttausend aus dem ganzen Land auf
den habinerplatz im Herzen von Tel Aviv
gekommen sie alle demonstrieren hier
weil sie eine Regierung mit
ultra-orthodoxen und ultrazionisten
fürchten für die das Judentum über allem
steht die eine andere Herkunft oder
andere sexuelle Orientierung ausgrenzen
und den Rechtsstaat untergraben gegen
den wegen Korruption Angeklagten premier
netanjau hat schick mal Bresler schon
vor Jahren protestiert jetzt sei alles
noch viel schlimmer
komplett Lady die Balance zwischen den
Staatsgewalten komplett zu zerstören die
Regierung grundsätzlich über das
Justizsystem und die Gerichte zu stellen
das sind im Prinzip eins zu eins was in
Ungarn passiert und wir alle wissen
Ungarn ist keine Demokratie mehr
andere fürchten Israel könnte noch
tiefer sinken
ätherische chauffeette chemische müssen
wir eine Justiz bekommen die von
Politikern ernannt wird werden wir das
bekommen
es geht gegen ihn Benjamin netanjau und
seine neue Regierung in der sind
Extremisten und Rassisten so stark wie
nie mit einem Polizeiminister der
proaktiv eine harte Linie der Polizei
gegen oppositionelle Demonstranten
fordert mit einem Abgeordneten der gar
die Spitzen der Opposition wegen
Hochverrats verhaften lassen will am
gravierensten ist der geplante Umbau des
Rechtsstaats künftig soll die Knesset
mit absoluter Mehrheit Urteile des
Obersten Gerichtshofs über stimmen
können ein Angriff auf die
Gewaltenteilung auch Richter Staats und
Rechtsanwälte laufen Sturm dagegen die
Präsidentin des Obersten Gerichtshofs
mit einem dramatischen Appell
Justizsystem zerstören soll er wird
einen tödlichen Schlag gegen die
Unabhängigkeit der Richter führen dieser
Plan beabsichtigt die demokratische
Identität des Landes bis zur
Unkenntlichkeit zu entstellen Herr
Justizminister so geht das nicht
der angesprochene zeigt sich ungerührt
spricht den obersten Richtern die
Legitimation ab es zeigt sich das ist
noch eine Partei in Israel gibt eine die
nicht bei den Wahlen vor zwei Monaten
angetreten ist die sich aber trotzdem
über die knessel stellt und über die
Entscheidung des Volkes
ohne Zweifel hat diese Regierung eine
Mehrheit und doch ist das Land gespalten
wie nie
Israels Demokratie steht im 75 Jahr nach
ihrer Gründung am Scheideweg
in einem Land dessen Menschen Diskussion
Argumente Streit so sehr lieben müssen
sie Angst haben um ihr Recht zu
demonstrieren mit seinen 80 Jahren hat
der ehemalige premier und
Verteidigungsminister erholt Barak viel
gesehen er sagt schlimme Dinge passieren
wenn gute Bürger still sind
Hanna du hast jetzt die
Nachrichtenübersicht die britische
Regierung hat die Lieferung schwerer
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine angekündigt
konkret geht es um Panzer vom Typ
Challenger 2 die genaue Anzahl ist noch
unklar Großbritannien ist damit das
erste Land das Kiew moderne Kampfpanzer
bereitstellt unterdessen hat Russland
die Ukraine massiv mit Raketen
beschossen in der Stadt nie pro starben
nach ukrainischen Angaben mindestens
neun Menschen beim Angriff auf ein
Hochhaus mindestens 60 sein verletzt
worden außerdem wurde erneut gezielt die
kritische Infrastruktur des Landes
angegriffen
in Deutschland ist ein zweites
schwimmendes lng-terminal im Betrieb
genommen worden nämlich in Lubmin an der
Ostsee Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns
Ministerpräsidentin Schwesig eröffneten
heute die Anlage eine weitere gibt es in
Wilhelmshaven durch den Import von
verflüssigem Erdgas sollen Teile der
ausbleibenden russischen Gaslieferungen
ersetzt werden
der Iran hat den ehemaligen
Verteidigungsminister des Landes Alireza
aquari hingerichtet der neben der
iranischen auch die britische
Staatsbürgerschaft besaß er war wegen
angeblicher Spionage zum Tode verurteilt
worden als Reaktion zog Großbritannien
den britischen Botschafter in Teheran
vorübergehend ab und verhängte
Sanktionen gegen den Generalstaatsanwalt
auch Frankreich Deutschland und die USA
verurteilten die Hinrichtungen
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen in
Tschechien hat keiner der Bewerber die
erforderliche Mehrheit von 50% erreicht
Ex-Regierungschef Babisch und der
frühere Nato-General Pavel ziehen
deshalb in die Stichwahl ein laut den
amtlichen Daten der tschechischen
Statistikbehörde liegt Pavel nach
Auszählung fast aller Wahlbezirke nur
knapp vor barbisch die Stichwahl findet
in zwei Wochen statt
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 6 12 24 38 42 43 Superzahl 3 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
es gibt eine Unwetterwarnung des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in Teilen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen und regnerisch sind
auch die Aussichten für die kommenden
Tage morgen im Süden länger Regen in
höheren Lagen zunehmend Schnee ab dem
Nachmittag von Nordwesten Schauer und
einzelne Gewitter bei einem stürmischen
Südwestwind 5 bis 12 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen wird das Kühler von
Westen immer wieder neuer Regen oberhalb
von 300 bis 500 Metern Schnee ab
Mittwoch freundlicher
Gottfried Silbermann geboren am 14
Januar
1683 in
kleinbobritzsch war ein Genie schon zu
Lebzeiten galten die Kirchenorgeln die
er baute als das beste was einem zu
Ohren kommen kann
zu seinem 340 Geburtstag heute verbinden
sich alle komplette erhaltenen
Silbermann Orgeln die es noch gibt und
das sind in Sachsen Brandenburg
Thüringen und Bremen 32 Stück zu einem
einmaligen Ständchen dass wir uns nicht
entgehen lassen sollten
[Musik]
und damit bringen wir Sie in diese
Samstagnacht und sind sehr gerne morgen
wieder für Sie da einen angenehmen
[Musik]